trump in the future is going to do what  he sees is best for himself it might be  bad for the republican party trump was  not a republican much of his life he  concocted this whole republican persona  in order to run and we we've talked  about that before  and trump is going to continue doing  what's best for him and it might  conflict with what's best for the  republican party if trump might do  something next year or the year after  that would be bad for the republican  party not only should we let him do it  we should encourage him to do it um if  he  only if if he followed through with this  threat the left would be in a far better  position going into 22 and 24. um but uh  trump did not ultimately leave the  republican party because at the end of  the day he accepted and recognized and  agreed that it would be bad for him  financially to do that trump has never  really been a republican trump serves  his interests he has his own agenda  that's all he cares about